a u.s transporter plane approaches kabul
airport through the late afternoon sun
apache helicopters circling watching the
runway checking if it's clear and if
it's safe to land
even a reaper drone is dispatched to
oversee the plane's arrival
but it isn't safe
listen as it pulls away
even the military can't land now
and this is why utter pandemonium on the
entire airfield hundreds of afghans
having breached all security swarming
around air force planes attempting to
clamber on board
they're desperate to get away from this
country destination anywhere but here
eventually the plane did take off
we won't show the picture but minutes
later two people fell to their deaths
it's chaos outside the terminal as well
thousands have descended onto the
airport road it's clogged up with people
and vehicles
afghan army and the taliban firing shots
into the air trying to push the crowds
back other talibs try their more
traditional method of crowd control
if you do get past this is what you can
expect
the airport is surrounded by huge blast
walls but even here they clamber up
trying to make their way through gaps in
the cement
the international airlift has been
seriously compromised
throughout the day the sound of gunfire
reverberated around us and it's near
two apache helicopters circled above
monitoring the source of the shooting an
overwatch of the mayhem below
at times there was a clear exchange of
fire by whom remains unknown
there's a lot of gunfire um outside the
compound we're staying in helicopters
have been up now for a while
providing uh cover
the taliban are in the streets outside
it goes up to the civilian part of the
airport
they're totally in control of this area
in contrast the city proper remains
remarkably calm
it's the usual result when the taliban
come to town and have they come to town
the city is awash with taliban fighters
and to all intents and purposes they
control all districts of kabul
on street corners and at all
intersections they oversee kabul's
residence as slowly but surely the
capital comes back to life after being
deserted
it's still quiet by kabul standards but
that is changing
what is striking is the amount of
sophisticated equipment they have taken
from the afghan military rows of armored
personnel carriers humvees and trucks
are parked on larger roads
the fighters patrol around town in their
traditional pickup trucks all armed to
the teeth for a battle that in reality
they have actually won
other fighters passed through their
checkpoints in their newly acquired
vehicles
in groups they were relaxed and happy to
be filmed
20 years ago this would have been all
but unthinkable and certainly not
without the permission of senior
commanders
khari bashir in his new special forces
helmet says people in kabul are getting
used to the idea of a new reformed
taliban
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
the truth is that thousands may be
millions of afghans and much of the
international community don't believe
they will have changed their ways or
forgive people with links to foreign
powers they disagree
while the taliban creates its new
government and the world watches on
the effort to remove foreigners and
their afghan employees continues
the truth is that in this chaos the
foreigners will become a priority and
like afghanistan itself the afghans will
likely be left behind